[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
moin zusammen wir sind zurück mit einer
neuen Ausgabe hier ist Natalie Strauß
und hier ist Mirko Kasimir und da ich
hier der ältere von uns beiden bin fange
ich heute mal an mit unserem Fall am 15
juli 1990 ist man in Deutschland
schockiert erstens weil jemand den alle
mochten ermordet worden ist und zweitens
weil der der ermordet wurde anders war
als alle dachten so klang das in der
Tagesschau der 64-Jährige
Volksschauspieler Regisseur und Autor
Walter Sedlmeier ist gestern in seiner
Münchner Wohnung ermordet aufgefunden
worden nach ersten Erkenntnissen der
Polizei wurde der Schauspieler
ausgeraubt
in diesem Haus in der Elisabethstraße in
München Schwabing wurde Walter Sedlmayr
gestern um 21 Uhr von seinem
Privatsekretär tot aufgefunden nach
einem vorläufigen Obduktionsbericht
starb der beliebte Schauspieler an
Schlägen auf den Kopf und mehreren
Messerstichen der genaue Zeitpunkt des
Mordes ist noch nicht bekannt das letzte
Lebenszeichen sedlmeiers gab es am
Samstagnachmittag die Polizei geht davon
aus dass der Schauspieler den oder die
Täter gekannt hat da die Wohnungstür
nicht beschädigt ist möglicherweise
wurde ein Raubmord nur vorgetäuscht die
Ermittlungen konzentrieren sich auf das
Homosexuellen Milieu zu dem weil der
Sedlmayer Kontakt hatte bereits 1982 war
Sedlmeier Opfer eines Raubüberfalls
die reichhaltige schauspielerische
Durchbruch gelangen im gebürtigen
Münchner 1972 Hans-jürgen süperberg
hatte in seinem Film die Rolle des Leib
Kochs von Ludwig dem zweiten mittwalder
Sedlmeier besetzt für die solistische
Meisterleistung erhielt er ein Jahr
später den Bundesfilmpreis
für Sedlmeier mussten die Rollen immer
originell sein Menschen mit eindeutig
bayerischer Lebensart ohne das von ihm
verabscheute weiß blaue Heimat Klischee
lagen immer am meisten
in seinem Element war der Regisseur und
Schauspieler der mit seinen eigenwillig
unterhaltsamen Reiseberichten den
sogenannten Sedlmayr Tourismus populär
gemacht hat auf dem Nockherberg beim
alljährlichen Stich das prominenten der
blicken mit spitzer Zunge das konnte
wohl keiner so gut wie er
folgt und muss sich selber entscheiden
also ein äußerst beliebter bayerischer
Volksschauspieler ist in München
ermordet worden wieder durch erst
bekannt wird war er schwul und alles am
Tatort spricht erstmal dafür dass er
beim Sex ermordet wurde Kondome Gleitgel
eine Peitsche den Fall übernimmt
Kriminaloberrat Josef Wilfling von dem
hören wir gleich noch mehr aber erstmal
wollen wir Walter Sedlmeier kennenlernen
Mirko Walter siedemeier wird am 6 januar
1926 in München geboren als Sohn des
Tabak Händlers Richert und der Hausfrau
Maria Rott er ist ein schwieriger
Schüler und wechselt mehrfach die
Gymnasien bis er im Kriegsjahr 1945 ein
Notabitur macht
in den letzten Wochen der Kämpfe muss er
wie viele seiner Mitschüler als
Flakhelfer arbeiten nach dem Krieg
entdeckt er seine Leidenschaft für die
Schauspielerei er spielte an mehreren
Münchner Theater den Kammerspielen
bleibt der 25 Jahre lang treu aber ein
richtiger Durchbruch ist lange nicht in
Sicht sedemeier macht später auch Filme
spielt hauptsächlich in kleinen
Nebenrollen mit Stars wie Heinz Rühmann
iselotte Pulver und OWi Fischer ich muss
aber ehrlich sagen das sind alles Sachen
die ich erstmal googeln musste aber wir
dürfen uns das mit sedelmeyer übrigens
nicht zu einfach machen obwohl er später
als Volksschauspieler gilt arbeitet der
Anfang der 70er Jahre mit Rainer Werner
fastbinder Fassbinder ist der
anspruchsvolle und sperrige
Filmregisseur seine Zeit er wird später
berühmt mit Berlin Alexanderplatz in
dieser Fassbinder Phase passiert bei
Sedlmeier auch etwas skurriles oha das
kann man wohl sagen
1971 wird aus dem Schloss Rotenburg im
Münchner Nordwesten eine Madonna
gestohlen und die taucht wenig später in
dem Haus im stadtteilfeld moching auf in
dem sedelmayr wohnt deshalb landet er
tatsächlich dann auch in U-Haft er kommt
aber nach fünf Tagen frei und verurteilt
werden später drei Männer die schon
andere Diebstähle begangen haben aber
die irrtümliche Verdächtigung erweist
sich als eine Art Karrierekick für
Sedlmeier plötzlich kennen ihn alle er
spielt ab jetzt in großen Fernsehserien
wir Münchner Geschichten oder
Polizeiinspektion 1 über die Jahre wird
er zum bekannten Gesicht Bayerns tritt
beim Kabarett im Fernsehshows und beim
Radio auf was fehlt in Bayern
bei Bayern und bayerische Schauspieler
gab es genug damals schon aber einer hat
gefehlt der
etwas schwierige Bayer
den habe ich dann allmählich zum
Grantler gemacht und der Grantler der
bayerische
Mist eigentlich und die
Hintergrundgeräusche in diesem Interview
stammen übrigens von sedlmeiers eigenem
Restaurant denn im Februar 1989 eröffnet
er die Gastwirtschaft beim sedelmeyer an
der westenrieder Straße 14 in München na
dem Viktualienmarkt hier gibt es passend
zum Image des Chefs original bayerische
Küche von schwammerlsuppe bis Weißwurst
kurz gesagt sieht im Sommer 1990 alles
bestens aus dem Leben von Walter
Sedlmeier er ist als Schauspieler Kult
als Geschäftsmann erfolgreich und
mittlerweile mehrfacher Millionär
außerdem handelt er mit Kunst und
Antiquitäten aber wie es innen aussieht
bei Sedlmeier wie sich sein Leben
anfühlt das ist vielleicht etwas anderes
denn er ist schwul und keiner soll es
Wissen in sedemeiers Jugend führt
Homosexualität tatsächlich noch ins
Konzentrationslager wohl schwule Männer
um erzogen gefoltert oder sogar
kastriert werden aber auch in der jungen
Bundesrepublik wird Liebe unter Männern
verfolgt es gibt den § 175 der schwule
sexuelle Handlungen unter Strafe stellt
ich finde das übrigens sowas von krass
wie lange bei uns noch schwule verfolgt
wurden
50.000 Männer wurden in der
Bundesrepublik abgeurteilt erst ab 1969
warum muss Sexualität und Erwachsenen in
Westdeutschland damit erst straffrei da
war die DDR früher dran im Osten wurde
das Delikt Unzucht zwischen Männern
schon 1957 auf sexuelle Handlung mit
Jugendlichen unter 21 Jahren beschränkt
Erwachsene schwule waren also keiner
Verfolgung ausgesetzt fest steht viele
Männer leben ihre Homosexualität
heimlich aus und das natürlich erst
recht wenn man wie weiter seeleyer als
Schauspieler im katholischen Bayern
Erfolg haben wollte heimlich schwul sein
das hieß anonymer Sex in dunklen
Hinterzimmern oder käuflicher Sex mit
männlichen Prostituierten sogenannten
Strichern das konnte aber auch bedeuten
dass man sich erpressbar macht wem kann
man also Vertrauen bei der Wahl von
Strichern vielleicht half dem Star
sedelmayr bei der Auswahl seinen
bekannter Wolfgang Wehrle auf jeden Fall
verbindet Sedlmeier und den fast 30
Jahre jüngeren Wehrle über die Jahre
eine so enge Freundschaft das letzterer
irgendwann einfach nur als sedl Meiers
Ziehsohn gilt eine wichtige und
vertrauensvolle Rolle spielt auch
sedlmeiers Privatsekretär Werner Darms
er hatte zwar noch Abitur gemacht war
aber danach wohl in Münchens kriminelle
Halbwelt abgerutscht zu seinen Jobs
gehörte Taxi fahren und dabei lernte er
jede Maja kennen im Sommer 1990 soll
sich Walter Sedlmeier also in seinem
Erfolg als Schauspieler und wird
dass er schwul ist wissen nur wenige
vertraute er ist jetzt 64 Jahre alt und
hat noch viel vor mittlerweile ist er
zum Beispiel auch als Reisejournalist
erfolgreich aber dann passierte etwas
Schreckliches
[Musik]
am 15 juli 1990 findet Privatsekretär
Darms Sedlmayr Tod im Schlafzimmer in
dessen Wohnung in der Elisabethstraße 5
in München Schwabing vor der Tote liegt
im Bett auf dem Bauch er hat eine
riesige Wunder im Hinterkopf in seinem
Körper steckt auf der linken Seite noch
ein Messer mit dunklem griff auf dem
Laken ist alles voller Blut im
Schlafzimmer finden sich zahlreiche
Spuren von Sex Kondome Gleitcreme
Sadomaso Utensilien wie eine Peitsche
Deutschland ist schockiert vom Mord an
einem der beliebtesten Schauspieler und
verwundert darüber dass der scheinbar so
konservative Mann schwul war heutzutage
das normalste der Welt aber damals noch
ein echter Skandal besonders im
erzkonservativen Bayern besonders
traurig ist dass man Sedlmeier im
Rückblick hat fallen lassen wie eine
heiße Kartoffel also zu Beerdigung
erschien weder prominente noch der
damalige Ministerpräsident Max Streibl
und auch die Brauerei die mit
sehrdemeier gestorben hat ließ alle
Plakate mit ihm abhängen den Mordfall
übernimmt Kriminaloberrat Josef Wilfling
es war sehr komplizierter und
schwieriger Fall der sich ja über drei
Jahre hingezogen hat es gab nichts
im Bereich Kriminologie
Kriminalistik was hier nicht tangiert
war Wilfling ist schon früh klar das ist
ein großer Fall rückblickend sagt er so
etwas vergisst man nicht bei jedem Toten
erkennt man an den Verletzungen was das
Opfer mitgemacht hat diese unglaubliche
Brutalität und der Hass der sich da
entladen haben muss das hat sich mir
eingeprägt das war wirklich eine
Exekution es gab in diesem Fall auch die
ersten Versuche mit DNA dafür sind wir
mit Zigarettenstummeln die am Tatort
gefunden worden waren sogar zu Scotland
Yard gereist auf die Belohnung übertraf
alles bisher da gewesene 500.000 Mark
wurden von den Nachlassverwaltern
ausgelobt 5000 vom Staat das Wilfling so
gründlich gearbeitet hat wird den wahren
Tätern zum Verhängnis denn sie haben
alles darauf angelegt dass der Tatort
nach einem Mord im Stricher Million
aussieht aber der Kommissar und seine
Kollegen verlassen sich nicht auf
oberflächliche Hinweise es waren
Utensilien sexutensilien
überall im Schlafzimmer drapiert
Presser war diese Peitschen Gleitcreme
und solche Dinge und das sollte wohl bei
uns den Eindruck erwecken als hätte da
etwas Sexuelles stattgefunden wir
konnten das aber durchschauen und
insbesondere konnten wir nachweisen dass
diese
Utensilien die da drapiert wurden mit
seinem wirklichen Sexualverhalten nichts
zu tun hatten weil wir dann in den
folgenden Monaten 50 Sexualpartner
sedlmeiers ermittelt haben in der
sogenannten Stricher Szene und die
natürlich völlig unabhängig voneinander
ein Bild gezeichnet haben wie die
Besuche bei ihm wirklich abgelaufen sind
es stellt sich heraus sedlmaiers
Vorlieben beim bezahlten Sex waren
völlig harmlos er wollte nur ein
bisschen zuschauen ohne Berührungen
Kondome oder gar Peitschen hätte er
deshalb niemals
das deckt sich auch mit der Autopsie
sedlmaiers Samenbläschen war gefüllt er
hatte vor seinem Tod also keinen
Orgasmus Wilfling weiß jetzt mit was er
ist nicht zu tun hat aber wer war der
wahre Mörder und was war sein Motiv nach
der Tat stand der Tresor offen entwendet
wurden offenbar mehrere tausend D-Mark
Bargeld Goldmünzen und Familienschmuck
also war es jetzt doch nur ein einfacher
Raub aber warum wurde Sedlmayer dann so
grausam gequält und ermordet in einem
Testament das nach sedlmaiers Tod
auftaucht ist Privatsekretär Werner
Darms als Erbe mit seiner Familie
benannt er hat zwei kleine Kinder ihm
Stunden also vier Häuser eine
Eigentumswohnung ein Grundstück und
Sparkonten zur Verfügung Gesamtwert ca
15 Millionen D-Mark im Testament finden
sich aber auch für Sedlmeier völlig
untypische Rechtschreibfehler es ist
eine ziemlich armselige Nummer die hier
auffliegt Sekretär Darms findet den
Toten Chef und wittert das große Geld er
fällt das Testament zu seinen Gunsten in
einem Prozess wegen Urkundenfälschung
sagt der laut BILD München damals ich
war in Panik es war ein irrsinniger
Fehler aber ich wollte dass mein Leben
wie bisher im Wohlstand weitergeht da
habe ich halt einen Ausweg konstruiert
Darms wird zu 18 Monaten verurteilt das
Mordes ist aber nicht verdächtig aber er
bringt die Polizei auf die richtige Spur
denn Darms hat mitbekommen dass es
mächtig Stress gab zwischen Sedlmaier
und seine zieh Sohn Wolfgang Wehrle der
Vertraute sedlmaiers war auch dessen
companion im Restaurant beim segelmayer
nur dass das Verhältnis im zweiten
Geschäftsjahr völlig zerrüttet war
Sedlmaier ist sicher dass Wehrle
Einnahmen des Betriebes für sich behielt
deshalb lässt er neuerdings das Geld
jeden Abend abholen im Gegenzug verwehrt
Wehrle Sedlmaier und seinem Sekretär
Darms den Zutritt zum Lokal der Streit
ist schon so weit eskaliert das
sedelmeyer seinen sogenannten zieh Sohn
aus dem Betrieb werfen will da ist also
ein handfestes Motiv der Ziese und
kämpft um seinen Anteil am Betrieb um
seinen Reichtum Kommissar Wilfling setzt
verdeckte Ermittler auf Werder an und
kann so auch ermitteln dass er wohl ein
mietäter hatte sein Halbbruder Manfred
laubers Frau ist es dann auch die einen
entscheidenden Baustein für die Anklage
liefert sie vertraut einem von wilflings
V-Leuten an dass der Hammer mit dem
Sedlmeier erschlagen wurde aus ihrem
Haushalt stammt aus Sicht des Kriminal
oberrats ist der Fall im Wesentlichen
gelöst einzig einen möglichen dritten
Mann dessen Spur angeblich nach Kroatien
führt kann er nie aufspüren geschweige
denn verhaften aber Wilfling übergibt
der Staatsanwaltschaft jetzt
Ermittlungsakten die die Tat so
darstellen
[Musik]
der 14 Juli 1990 ist ein Sonnabend
Sedlmeier verbringt ihn wie die meisten
Wochenenden allein mit Dackel Moritz in
seiner großen Wohnung in der
Elisabethstraße 5 heute hat er um 18 Uhr
mit dem Koch im Gasthaus beim Sedlmayr
telefoniert ihnen hat er als Nachfolger
seines Kompagnons Wehrle vorgesehen um
19 Uhr ruft Schauspielkollegin Maria
Nicklisch an das tut sie jeden Samstag
aber diesmal geht keiner ran denn kurz
zuvor ist Sedlmeier überfallen worden
als sie in der Bibliothek saß und wie
üblich eine Zigarette der Marke laut
extra rauchte Wolfgang Wehrle der einen
Schlüssel zur Wohnung hatte überrumpelt
Sedlmeier zusammen mit seinem Halbbruder
Manfred Lauber sie zerren ihn ins
Schlafzimmer schmeißen ihn bäuchlings
aufs Bett und fesseln ihn an Händen und
Füßen da muss auch so wahnsinnig viel
Hass und Wut dabei gewesen sein das
waren wirklich grausame Minuten die
Männer stechen ihm mit einem 30 cm
langen Messer in die Niere und verletzen
ihn schwer an der Kehle und am Ende
zertrümmern sie Sedlmayr Schädel mit
einem Hammer die Täter verteilen die
pseudo-spuren am Tatort die ein Stricher
Mord vortäuschen sollen aber 1993 werden
sie in einem Indizienprozess zur
Rechenschaft gezogen und zu lebenslanger
Haft verurteilt die Halbbrüder
bestreiten die Tat auch weiterhin aber
eine Wiederaufnahme des Verfahrens wird
ihm mehrfach verweigert zuletzt im Jahr
2005 Schlagzeilen machen die beiden ein
paar Jahre später noch mal als sie ihre
Strafen abgesessen haben da wollen sie
dass in der Presse und damit auch im
Internet niemand Ihre vollständigen
Namen nennen darf sie begründen das mit
ihrem Persönlichkeitsrecht aber der
Bundesgerichtshof verwehrt das und
verweist auf die Meinungsfreiheit
[Musik]
Kriminaloberrat Josef Wilfling sagte der
TZ
Sedlmeier war ein Opfer der Intoleranz
der damaligen Gesellschaft er war ein
einsamer Mann wäre er nicht zu diesem
Doppelleben gezwungen gewesen hätte er
sich nie mit diesen kriminellen
eingelassen
das war's für heute wir danken euch dass
ihr dabei wart wir haben diesen Fall
recherchiert mit historischen Artikeln
aus dem Archiv von Bild der Abendzeitung
und der TZ das Griff hat Stefan Netze
Bank geschrieben Postproduktion durch
wake-word München hoffentlich hören wir
uns beim nächsten Mal wieder bis ganz
bald eure Natalie und euer Mirko